[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we have Chris here today Chris ain't no
[ __ ]
I ain't no [ __ ] man what's that about
Chris I'm just tired of being one so
well so that's your like your shirt yeah
this is my merch this is my merch I
ain't no [ __ ] to something I've always
said all the time like it's just
something that's like motivates me for
anything like if I got to pay the the
check you know I mean who's gonna split
it like you know I know [ __ ] I'm gonna
take care of all of it yeah yeah I don't
have it good I'll eat sometimes we can
so you don't be a [ __ ] yeah that'll be
the death of me one you know you could
get so many favors off of them she's got
a Marty McFly with Back to the Future we
call the chicken yeah that's the thing
yeah that's really cuz like I'm a
smaller guy you don't mean they're
taller than me what are you talking
about I mean I'm slimmer you know I'm
sudden guy yeah I mean and I I've always
gotten that just I was always smaller in
school people are always talking [ __ ]
and I always be like up to me I know
[ __ ] though you don't mean I grew up
boxing yeah I got I guess I'm taller I'm
pretty short but I'll bite your [ __ ]
nuts yeah it's about doubt my thing that
was my thing I should go I know [ __ ]
though you know so I'm actually scared
of shorter people than bigger people why
as short man syndrome is [ __ ] me yes
for real what my most scariest and
violent friends were always short yeah
they got their short tempers you have a
lot to prove you got a lot of stuff yeah
short tempered short fuse I'm like oh
cause I sure yeah yeah they're limited
their patience is short
yeah but they insisting on regular-sized
dicks though that what they always
insist they have regular to big sized
dicks I always love that when somebody
talks about how they have a big dick
it's really funny to me yeah well I did
see a porno of a little person with a
human like massive dicks I was like okay
well that's not fair cuz he's shorter
than me and he's [ __ ] me oh yes [ __ ]
tripod stuff yep yeah what what do you
do that makes you go oh I'm a [ __ ] oh I
feel like that you Flo you have to
remind yourself all the time I ain't no
[ __ ]
I get I get hella like emotional you
know
like that and it comes from like I don't
know I don't know like the zodiacs up
but people here I'm a cancer they're
like oh my god you're so sensitive
and I get on my old dad makes sense you
know me because I always I have moments
where like I just get like I started my
man I gotta get a little emotional I
started taking things offensive you know
mean like and I'm in a comedy game to
what you saw ironic yeah they're like
I'll just yeah roasting and I'm laughing
down in this leg hmm so it's not a game
anymore yeah yeah yeah but I'll stay in
it but I'll be in the car just crying
like that so it's really but to be able
to admit that that's actually opposite
of being a [ __ ] I'm not sure yeah if
your shirt
maybe we can adjust your murse love it
it could be I ain't no [ __ ] I ain't no
[ __ ] I ain't no [ __ ] I ain't a [ __ ]
so because it's almost sounds like
you're like psyching yourself up or
something it's like is it ain't no [ __ ]
ain't no [ __ ] no [ __ ] I you know [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] it's like you're about to
go to war so yeah it's it's one of those
like like before you get on stage like
people say that they have butterflies
like in or like it's a big crowd we're
not performing in Vegas in front of like
2500 people for the first time my
biggest crowd I was like and then I was
it was actually for Mike guess he he put
me on like two hostess Oh sick yeah so
it was a dope gig and stuff like that
and I it was like before I got on I was
like whoo I just had it like a moment
but then I was like you know what [ __ ] I
ain't no [ __ ] and that's that's kind of
something that like kick-starts me mean
like that same thing for like skydiving
I'm gonna skydive for the first time it
was like this year yeah I love your
shirt because I completely understand
what that means but it's been lost like
a like a Egyptian hieroglyph in the
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] millennial era
yeah yeah yeah twist that meaning to say
other things and it's just changing and
I'm like why especially in what culture
it's like you're wrong with [ __ ]
would not choose as we consign
it doesn't mean female in any way no
like coward yeah that's what that's yeah
they said that's exactly how to just
like I'm not I'm not I don't want to be
weak you know mean and Ike and that's an
S one upstanding to because I'm really
in tune with like being sensitive and
like empathizing and always like
considering people's feelings and know
what trying to make sure everybody is
okay bill you know it just means no
courage yeah yeah yeah yeah that's hot
ticket what do you know about saying
like hey man don't be a little [ __ ] oh
man I can't even like the word [ __ ] to
be honest really I love I can't for me I
love [ __ ] so much and you don't might
be a my being but I can't like I don't
like the work cuz even like when it's
about to go down or me when I talk about
with a girl I don't when I say it I feel
like I'm in a porno like it seems too
extreme to me either I don't just say
[ __ ] I'll just say like go downtown
yeah I'm going down but I'm saying no
like I don't I'm going down here but I'm
going down I'm going downtown
no but cuz I'm saying if I could if I
say it's gonna end up being like hey I
think I got it is in the scares you yeah
like this is the words it's a weird too
extreme for me what happens just a
Southern gentleman he doesn't say those
kind of I'll say [ __ ] is business
you're like yeah yeah so what I mean the
southern gentleman doesn't think of
those kind of yeah I don't I don't have
words for it to be honest I don't have
words for but I know I know for sure I
don't say that's not my thing
look what Spanish words like but no try
not cha know Rama
we call it a panorama though
so when I hit up Chris because Kevin
stage Kevin he suggested crispy on and
so I he was like you know what's crazy
you guys talked about my dad I was like
what oh yeah dad yeah we did an article
by your dad on his dad so you guys
remember this this is the guy who faked
his own death because of his wife was
planning on killing him
what is that your mom this photo oh yeah
that's my buzz so tell us wait wait wait
wait your is your dad the guy that faked
that in the past thing yeah yeah isn't
now that was the stage that was the
stage it looks different from the
picture that when he's pretending to be
alive well pretending to be alive well
cause he's that looks like a white guy
one looks like a black guy my dad oh
[ __ ] right now she looks like cute you
know it's funny so I rewatched the video
and the only person saying anything
commenting anything on his dad it was
huge Oh what do you mean you're the only
one I talk a lot of [ __ ] yeah you do
let's talk more [ __ ] look he looks white
when he's dead yeah it's white Bucky's
in dirt why it's like a white guy for
sure that's a picture of a picture a
picture of a picture but that look he's
right so I was right you guys are insane
no he's supposed to look pale because
he's dead like he's lifeless
so wait what black people don't turn
white when they got it
we just really ten yeah what is it
Dominica he's put her again to make it
yeah but you don't like Don Rickles when
you die get the picture of a picture you
like you know when you take up you know
like a film picture and it just looks
darker yeah yeah just the lighting just
a larger dad alike yeah are you guys
friends yeah he's actually I just
dropped them over there for today
actually yeah like is he gonna talk
about what happened what happened yeah
okay so um what about the episode was
funny when you are talking about it and
then during during that time I hope I
didn't offend you cuz I talk a lot of
[ __ ]
okay no my family like we are like we'd
take nothing series so even with that
situation I were trolling Monday I'm
gonna start crying in the car after this
yeah the shirt the shirt don't forget
don't forget no so yeah yeah um it was
like uh-huh things like four years now
or three or four years ago but I was
living out here and my dad was with that
no that's not that's not my mom by the
way so let's let's get that off but
people feel were coming like yo your mom
bro like no I know that's not my mama my
dad got remarried and she was like she
already had a weird vibe and just offer
it you know I mean like it was a weird
vibe to her she was super like she
treated my dad like a king and it was
but the way that she looked at us the
way she looked at other other family
members she just kind of gave like that
you know like in Lion King when not well
she was like walking through the mom and
I was like hatin on her she kind of had
that vibe you know just hating on her
you know I mean we're just like go what
should what should this energy just
weird you know me but my dad was in love
with her so we're cool we loved it too
yeah and um that what started happening
was my dad he's like very prideful of
his kids so he really like put like my
you know his sons in Hollywood my dad
thinks I made it every best oh no when
he came out here he was putting it
almost like everywhere we went you know
I mean and I performed yesterday too so
that was another thing for him to it was
just always exciting for him so he puts
all this stuff on both Facebook and puts
was like on the refrigerator that that
dad you know she has kids and they're
like they're they're not so good yet I
mean like they're kind of like they're
kind of rough and they they weren't
really good in school and grades weren't
there like and so she would always have
excuses like well they didn't have a dad
and not their life and there's so she
would be kind of bitter every time my
dad was like like prese
she'd be bitter about it because her
kids are like how come you don't so
jealous yeah it was like an envious type
of thing yeah I mean so my dad was like
I don't tell you don't mean these are my
kids and my kids just better than yours
yeah you know
crazy cuz you gotta think really hard to
develop that kind of jealousy like your
jealousy that your kid that did your
kids didn't have a father but then
you're angry at your potential fault you
just know that he wasn't praising them
the way he was breathing uh probably
yeah I would I would think so but then
but my thing is like if me if the kid is
being like low [ __ ] would admired
like praising you know didn't none of
this drives a man to want to fake his
own death what made him want to fake his
own death well that's what yeah that
will they see all this all this is like
starting to add like it's it's building
up you know to me and like she's getting
hateful clashing yeah they're clashing
of stuff and it started getting to the
point where like it mind you and she's
from Mexico and she did an egg yeah this
is this also makes us look bad too like
she whenever they got married like the
week of getting married she wouldn't got
her paper like the green card she got
her sister said we got everything like
done deal like she's now got the
American Dream no she got it like that
it was quick you know me and then I Chi
and my dad was doing very like well up
there Houston he had like one of the
biggest boxing gyms in Houston she was
able to like finesse her way of like
being one of the trainers and having
half of the gym and like this is like
their thing and so she was really like
stunning and so whenever they started
clashing they started butting heads they
started they agreed on a divorce you
know he she had like my dad I served
with being his boss and this ain't his
first rodeo so he'll just say I ain't
trippin
you mean like alright you know what he's
down for it yeah so but she just started
doing crazy like she started like taking
pictures of them like trying to frame
him like putting like alcohol stuff by
his bed like bottles and stuff trying to
show he's an alcoholic
fake bruises and stuff like trying to
say that he like put his hands on her
and stuff and her dad just got out of
there he moved in with his mom and like
before it so that when the divorce was
cleared he can go back into his house
Wow and so during that time when its
before the divorce like I think it was
like a few months like they pros like
where I was gonna finalize and within
the two months
she had this idea of like a tort you
know on her own thing of like well if he
dies I'll just get all of it instead I
have like I'll get all of that so
sinister yeah I remember cuz I recently
watch that episode right I remember this
guy Gus was involved Oh his name's mundo
yeah it was not in this episode I have
no idea so okay so then your dad
confided in this other guy mundo and
then we were doing that so we were like
wait what about this guy like what is
good in him yeah yeah so so mundo my guy
that the the guy who really is the hero
in the dams and this whole story he um
he he was brought in like through boxing
as well my dad had a had a after-school
program and now he wasn't he was older
user he's already like grown me already
had like a past life here he had I give
a bad background you know I mean like he
was kind of he was in the streets and
you know little rough background but he
was like switching his life over and he
got into boxing and my dad just like
naturally became a mentor to him and
it's a grown man but uh like this is
like he still had his street smarts you
know I mean and he overheard of my dad's
yeah he overheard my dad's of ex-wife
like talking to somebody and you know in
Spanish like so many in Mexico whatever
but like she says the conversation was
kind of like you know if he's gone you
know just saying stuff like if he's gone
just that or I just wish that he was
gone to the whole thing and so he's he's
talking to her this after the gym
everybody's left my dad's not there he
hit her over say hey you know how's
everything like are you doing coke a
like I know things are a little rough at
home and the way that she was looking at
him she was just saying like oh god I
just wish everything was just done I
just wish that he could just be gone
like I just you know this whole thing
and then he's just kind of like looking
at her like like you are you like trying
to hire a hitman are you trying to you
know because I know people ya know so
the thing was is like he it snapped for
him real quick cuz he yeah he's he's he
said like he's seen the eyes of a
murderer before you know he knows that
look you know so when he saw that in her
he he took it upon himself
like he already died he left that
conversation she let that go and then
the next day like he told he told my dad
and my dad was just like man you know
anybody here is like man I think you're
watching tranquila
yeah it's crazy I mean like it's just
kind of like yeah yeah but then he was
just like he took it upon himself and
bought him a little tracfone and like to
record a conversation with her and he
asked her like yo like you feel like are
you down are you trying to do this cuz
like I know somebody you know I mean
that could and he's trying to make sure
that she gets in she gets in with him so
that she doesn't actually really go get
somebody that's smart and I'm saying
because he's like I'm trying to save my
mentor like this like his pops yeah he's
like I got you and he's trying to get
the way he convinced her to wear that
she she would trust him was that he was
like I just want a piece of it to like I
want a piece of the money you know I
mean Tori's like you know I you know I
know I know what what this what this
value is I'll go this way out of Texas
you go this one out of Texas and we'll
just do it like that you know to where
she was like all right like she trusted
to do like oh good mark let's go so then
we might what greed got to her no mundo
showed him the tape into my dad he was
my dad was like holy [ __ ] you know this
lady's for real trying to kill me man
and that was when they before I even got
to the cops they did their hole they had
their whole like mission you know I mean
like they actually like they they kept
they got another trap phone that was
like the Paco but that was the hit man
and ironically my dad was actually Paco
texting I wanna be I wanna [ __ ] do
this actually texting videos in and so
and so he's telling you no mundo telling
uh her name's Lulu look I'm gonna sound
a little about like yo this is Paco they
said get the number too long just so you
know he's gonna hit you up he's gonna
tell you about the price of stuff he's
so damn she's Tennessee sending text
messages to Paco to my dad messages that
are like saying like I don't have the
price that you're asking for but I can
offer you this much upfront cash and
then she's sending pictures of my dad's
cars
yeah pictures of my dad's jewelry yeah
like this is what I can give you and my
dad's looking at this like yo while
she's living in his home yeah yeah how
many gazes just happen over um this is
like in a course of like like for them
this is like like three or four days but
once they got all the text messages
evidence over that they went to the cops
yeah with all that all that evidence was
less I saw everything boys all like the
the recordings all those things that
evidence text messages they were like
okay like thanks you did our work yeah
basically basically bolide they put my
dad in LA in a hotel and like basically
off the radar hidden from us his family
like all like work that the job didn't
even know where was everybody was like
he was he was locked like in a hotel
whatever and they started like getting a
real like a real undercover cop with the
Hitman and who was gonna be Paco mundo
still had to stay in there because he
was the beginning of everything so he
had to stay in it and now he's miked and
stuff and they it's a whole movie so
movie man my dad got a book coming out
this summer too
that's crazy all the details and stuff
of what's going on in the marriage yeah
things like four years Wow yeah you
should turn this into a movie yeah it's
me is that your old man could like
whoever she was talking to Mexico or
whoever yeah that could have been a
person at all who attacked your dad in
that four days van so you're really just
saved like real no saved his life man
like how does your dad live day-to-day
now like I would still be scared even
though she's locked up Oh will my dad
will for sure he's he's out he's out of
that that part like that city you know I
mean like he still is he's so Houston
but it's different air does she get
anything still after committing those
crimes
she got 20 years in prison no I mean
like any of your dad's money and oh no
no no so that almost like takes
everything away yeah shame we got to for
you Center bet that's a crazy story man
dan this is weird it's a it's weird to
talk about your enemy is it was weird
with all that like when my dad called me
after that that that week where he
actually was able to contact everybody
he called me I'm in LA and I'm like I
would call me I'm like I haven't heard
from him you know I mean it's only
what's up pops
he's Chinese telling oh like you know so
you had no idea this was no idea I might
yell without past you know and he's like
he's like all kind of like son you know
take seat no they taste some I'm
thinking like oh damn who died not
knowing that he faked his death you know
me yeah but have you got the news that
he died before he even told you this oh
my god for it she was like I'm gonna
come out was that my grandma his mom
found out before he might before that my
dad could even car cuz my dad called us
and you know talking everybody but my
grandma found out the next day on the
news and she sees that that picture of
my dad this thing that's [ __ ]
traumatize that the caller like yo yo
you're like like this is everything was
going on yeah it's weird it's it's so
crazy because you see this stuff in
movies you don't know what like the
feeling is when it's like you you know
mean it's happening to you so it's like
what you know it makes moving sense man
yeah yeah it's why well you know that's
a based on a true story
yeah and I'm such a troll alot and being
the comedy I'm thinking of all the jokes
and material that I can get out of like
me this whole situation this crazy lady
my dad faking is death and faking the
death is kind of funny though it's
really fun because can you imagine like
the photoshoot or it's like now I gotta
look more dead yeah man yeah so I don't
and it was crazy is that
whenever he was getting like whenever
started getting viral he was like mr.
Hollywood hey son hey I'm viral son I
made it every time he called me was a
new country Japan son Japan
I'm on it guys send me a link whatever
yeah he sent me oh yeah man so shut up
dude yeah man he escaped death yeah oh
yeah his book is I walked on my own
grave that's the title I walked on my
own grave and she actually lost
everything cuz she would have just if
she just stuck with it she would have
had half the money they all had the
American dream that she won yeah but we
got to her everything yeah that's why
you know karma is awesome Instant Karma
is awesome dude in mundos getting a
Christmas card every [ __ ] year
yes mundo yeah no question mundo is the
real hero of words yeah you too man
mundo yes sir
[Music]